le cfcm élit son nouveau président mais
c'est quoi au juste le cfcm cfcm pour
conseil français du culte musulman
c'est lui qui représente les fidèles aux
yeux de l'état depuis 2003
alors ça c'est super mais avant le cfcm
c'était plus compliqué entre les
marocains et les algériens les turcs les
antillais ne me dis pas que c'est pas de
la même chose
il fallait trouver une instance commune
à tout un pan de sensibilité et de
pratiquer les musulmans sont divisés
comme d'autres comme partout quand même
dans le monde islamique
l'état veut un interlocuteur un seul
capable de structurer le culte dans tout
le pays en 1990 première tentative avec
le conseil de réflexion sur l'islam il
va servir à statuer sur l'islam de
france
ces missions organisées l'abattage
rituel de l'aïd la construction de
mosquées et les carrés musulmans dans
les cimetières
mais ce conseil de réflexion ne survivra
pas aux discordes entre les différents
courants musulmans c'est compliqué en
2001 le nouveau gouvernement annonce la
mise en place d'une nouvelle instance le
conseil français du culte musulman
mais encore en 2002 le dossier atterri
entre les mains du ministre de
l'intérieur et des cultes
nicolas sarkozy
mais encore ils affichent tout de suite
sa préférence pour la grande mosquée de
paris comme moteur de ce conseil
symbole d'un islam modéré voilà notre
islam celui qui respecte l'autre celui
qui s'insèrent pacifiquement dans les
institutions républicaines
celui qui apaise nos cités dalil
boubakeur recteur de la mosquée de paris
est élu premier président du cfcm pour
cette élection des délégués nommés dans
les mosquées et lisent les conseillers
régionaux du culte qui élisent les
membres du cfcm qui élisent le président
en 2003 les conseillers du cfcm issus
des différentes composantes de l'islam
tente d'afficher l'union et ce n'est pas
si évident il n'y a qu'à voir la photo
de groupe
[Musique]
un point d'accord cela dit le cfcm porte
la voix d'un islam modéré
parmi ces diverses missions deux sont de
taille la formation des imams et la
construction des mosquées
depuis ses débuts le cfcm c'est de la
diplomatie avec par exemple des
négociations pour libérer des otages à
bagdad
la condamnation d'attentât en france
comme à l'étranger
et ces dernières années la lutte contre
la radicalisation
mais depuis le début si le cfcm a fait
parler de lui c'est surtout pour ses
perpétuelles luttes intestines
[Musique]